et puis dans cette affaire l'avocat de
benjamin griveaux a laissé entendre que
la russie pourrait être impliqué richard
malka n'a pas hésité notamment à nommer
rt france qui a intenté en 2019 un
procès en diffamation contre l'ancien
porte parole du gouvernement notamment
pour ses propos concernant les
journalistes de cette rédaction
il accuse donc cette affaire d'être lié
à la chute de benjamin griveaux et
jérémie assous d'avocats d'ayrté france
lui affirme que les deux affaires n'ont
absolument rien à voir regarder on ne
peut pas faire la moindre connexion
entre les actions intentées par rt
france à l'encontre de l'ancien
secrétaire d'état et la sphère qui le
concerne
aujourd'hui les actions intentées par rt
france l'ont été dans le but est
uniquement dans le but de sauvegarder
l'honneur et la considération de ses
employés journalistes puisque benjamin
griveaux avait soutenu non pas une
reprise mais à deux reprises que ces
derniers n'étaient pas journaliste est
comme s'ils revenaient au secrétaire
d'état le pouvoir de qualifier ou
disqualifier une personne de journaliste
est donc juste titre la direction d'air
t france a considéré que c'était une
attaque extrêmement grave est que ça
remettait en considération sa remettait
en cause la considération et et
l'honneur de ses journalistes et donc à
demander à ce que la justice statue et
sanctionnent de tels propos et donc les
affaires sont en cours et elles vont
être jugés dans les mois à venir